week four part four what's going on guys
my name's David Thomas I'm a registered
architect here in Western Australia and
this is the completely free arcade
course right here on YouTube if you've
missed any of the parts so far make sure
you go back to part one so you
understand where we've come from and how
we've gotten to where we are today in
this video we are talking about walls in
their entirety we're going to be
breaking down how they work what the
Composites are and what you can do
effectively in arcad with the wall tool
the today's tutorial will be relatively
short sharp and sweet because there
isn't that much to cover with the actual
wall tool but let's get started and
actually break this down to the best of
abilities if we jump back to our ground
floor plan you remember we basically set
out most of our actual room design and
our house design so what we want to
First do is come up to our wall tool the
very first top left hand corner palette
you want to click on that and then start
by pressing command T I'm going to walk
through the settings first because this
is the most critical of all all of the
wall elements looking at our geometry
and positioning we're going to be able
to understand what this wall tool is and
how we're actually drawing our wall in
2D before we have to understand it in 3D
so first of all does our wall need to be
linked to anything the story settings we
set up previously will appear here and
you can either link it or not link it at
all so for me personally I'm just simply
going to link it to the first floor and
you're going to see it'll go minus 300
because our wall was previously two
seven four five if I just tap zero it
will then adjust our Wall height to 3045
which was the previous combination of
our ground floor plus all the structure
in between the two floors now the reason
I do this is to cover any of the
claddings that conceal the floor behind
it it's just very simple manner to do it
and also at the same time if your floor
levels ever change throughout the
project you can simply adjust one
setting through the command 7 and not
have to come in and change every single
height of every single wall you can also
detail where the wall starts from the
ground so at the moment it's starting
zero zero on the actual ground level so
I'm happy with that I'm not going to
change any of it just like slabs you
have different compositions for the
walls and the most common is your basic
composition if you select the layers
below it'll show you all of the Standard
wall types available to you in arcad now
this is the Australian select template
it has typical wall types for Australia
which means in your country these may be
significantly different for a reason
that reason being what you typically
construct in your country so for the
purpose of argument let's just select
this sp03 90 millimeter insulated stud
wall overall it's 110 millimeters 90
mils of structure and two layers of
plasterboard on either side if you
require the wall to be slanted angled
trapezoidal double slanted or any of the
above you can mess with these settings
here so for example if you want the wall
to be at a 45 degree angle you can
simply change that and it will be so for
the purpose of this we're going for very
straight walls for the current time the
reference line is where you will draw
your walls so I'll just showcase that
quickly now because it's too hard to
explain just verbally if I press OK and
zoom in down here start to draw my first
wall you'll see that the reference line
is on the outside face of our wall which
up here can be changed so if I change
that to Center the reference line or
where I click to start my wall is going
to now be in the center of the wall and
so on if I go inside face it'll be
inside face now it's the personal
preference and depends on your situation
your local codes and everything but
personally I like to go outside face and
then press the P button to make sure
that it aligns with the outside face so
if I simply finish up that wall for now
the reason I do that is if the wall
composition ever changes so let's say we
go from a 90 mil to a 270 brick work it
will shift everything inside and make
the internal smaller this usually
happens very late in the game to try and
save construction costs which means if
it goes out in Australia you have to go
back to the local authorities and get
their approval whereas when you push it
in there is no impact so that's
personally why I have my reference line
to the outside face but everybody's
different every country's regulations
are different and some people may want
to rather go back to council than mess
with the interior sizes of their spaces
so let's delete that wall press command
T open it back up to continue on where
we left off as you can see our reference
line is still set to the outside face
and our offset is zero being zero
meaning that it's using from the
plasterboard not from the structure if
you wanted to go from structure then you
can actually offset this to the size of
your cladding on the outside again this
is a pretty Advanced technique here so
you don't have to worry about it too
much when you're drawing your first
house your first box or whatever it is
you're trying to achieve this is going
to be a lot more complicated if you're
overthinking it our story settings plan
View and section are quite important as
well most of the time you only want to
see your walls on the home story but if
you want to see your walls on the story
above the story below or if you're
dragging one wall over two layers you're
going to want to simply just change this
from home story or only to all relevant
stories and in that way your wall will
show on all floors let me just showcase
that an example let's draw another wall
so that's our wall right there and it's
three meters and 45 millimeters tall if
I go into 3D you'll see it's that's all
so now coming back into ground floor
pressing Ctrl up up to go to my second
floor you won't see that wall at all
because it doesn't push through to that
second floor
however if I come back into my settings
let's extend that another 4 meters
higher so it's a seven meter tall wall
show it on all relevant stories press OK
double tap up you'll see it pushing all
the way through to that Second Story
similar if I was to simply just change
it to home Story Only press OK even
though it's seven meters tall as you can
see in the 3D it's not showing up on
that first floor so that is just the
documentation question that you need to
be aware of as you're progressing
throughout arcad typically it's going to
be on home story only so you don't have
to worry about it too much the floor
plan display is again a bit more of an
advanced method so it's going to be
talking about the projections the cuts
the cut symbols and everything between I
won't dive too much into this at this
point in time we might talk about it
later with doors but for now you just
basically want to be with projected with
overheads similar to show projection we
don't really need to go into that too
much if you do want to change the
overall look at the wall you can do it
in the outline section below and also
the cut through Wheels there is no
overrides it is going to be set up as
per the composition and the material
structures just like our slab tool we
can override these surfaces make it a
different color different texture do
whatever we wish by simply activating
the override surfaces and selecting a
new color not important for the timing
so I'll just keep that as unteaked last
but not least and one of the most
critical elements of the entire arcad
process is your layers so when you're
drawing external walls make sure they
are on the external walls when you're
drawing internal on internal and so
forth this is so critical for every
single thing that you do in arcad so
please keep looking at it keep reviewing
it and making sure your elements are on
the right layer you'll thank me later in
your iPad Journey so now let's press OK
delete that wall and simply start
drawing our new walls so let's start by
clicking on this foyer here and noticing
that our wall is going the wrong way we
still want our outside reference it's
still on the outside face why is it
facing the wrong way well I've CAD just
works sometimes that way and all you
need to do is press the P button for
Peter to flip that wall over now you'll
also see that the wall is relatively
freely moving and you can draw it in any
angle you want you're going to want to
hold the shift button basically every
time you draw any wall that you need to
be straight otherwise your dimensioning
tools and everything in between later
down the track isn't going to work so
get into the habit of holding the shift
button to make sure that it snaps to a
15 degree increment as you're actually
drawing so for me I'm just simply going
to hold the shift button come across the
other edge of the bedroom click once and
the wall will finish now I could repeat
that step click click click all the way
around I can select that wall hold my
option button press the delete to delete
the Wall come across up to the top to
our actual geometry structure press and
hold on a little arrow and go to my
polygonal straight wall
what this will allow me to do is first
of all again holding shift click once
and simply continue drawing my wall
around rather than having to click
multiple times so in this instance I can
simply go all the way around holding my
shift button finishing off my wall and
having all of my walls drawn very
quickly now if I select one of these
walls it's highlighted as just one
element but if I press option G it'll
unsuspend my groups which means you can
automatically select all of these walls
at once this is super handy as you start
drawing more and more walls if you're
option G or alt G button doesn't work
for any reason you can look up the top
for this symbol right here which will
suspend or unsuspend your group
suspending your groups will allow you to
select individuals unsuspending you can
select them all now let's move on to
internal walls the principle is
relatively the same thing select our
wall tool open up our settings find the
wall structure we like internally it
doesn't need to be insulated so let's
just pick the sp02 feature and change
from external to internal walls pressing
ok now you'll see once again our
internal walls are not shown on this
layer simply just double click on your
ground floor over here to reset our
layer settings as we require and now
when we come back into our wall tool
you'll see all of our settings are
correct and the war internal layer is
shown now there's nothing to be really
too cautious about when creating
internal walls except that you want to
be aligning with your external walls so
as you can see here if I was to draw
this wall I want my walls to align
equally so by simply drawing it in this
fashion here these two walls are going
to align perfectly rather than this wall
being offset somewhere over here and you
having an ugly little jut or a little
defect on site so you always want to
make sure that your external walls and
your internal walls are perfectly
aligned on the inside wherever they can
be that same process is going to be
applicable over here but that is
basically the only two places is that it
applies to now just like I drew the
external walls I can simply go around
keep clicking until I'm completely
finished with my design now I like to
have a lot of my walls grouped together
wherever possible to make life easy
later on but let's say you want to
extend just this section of the wall and
not draw a separate wall in its entirety
first of all you have to unsuspend your
groups by pressing option or alt G
selecting on that wall pressing on one
of the nodes moving across to your
floating toolbar and selecting the
stretch icon make sure you hold shift
guys because you want it to be straight
that'll extend that wall all the way
across and then you can hold your option
button to find one more wall and create
a wall in that section if you so choose
now personally I don't think that that
needs a wall so I'm going to delete that
and let that foyer be its own little
thoroughfare play area now if we come
back into our 3D model you'll see a
couple things going on here first of all
we have all of our external walls
fantastic but we also have all of our
internal walls kind of showing a little
bit strange first of all they're not
really here but they are cutting it to
our floor so what the hell is going on
well first of all just like the ground
floor plan the 3D view is very critical
for your layers so if we press command L
again type in wall and turn on our
internal wall pressing OK those internal
walls will be created clicking on your
scroll wheel you can pan around by
holding shift you can orbit around as
well and the scroll wheel zooming in and
zooming out will allow you to zoom in or
out if you don't like this method of
moving around the actual project
especially when you're getting inside
the building if you look down the bottom
left hand corner you see this little man
you can click the explore little button
and then you can play arcad just like a
video game so A S D and W will move your
camera up down left right you can also
use the up down left right arrows on
your keyboard the C button will move the
camera down the space button will move
the camera up and then all you have to
do with your mouse is look around like
you were in a first person shooter video
game and then you can fly in through
your building have a little wander
around look at your hallway look at your
walls understand your spaces a little
bit better and really get a sense of
what you're designing from a human scale
so flying down to our road level we
really get an understanding of what this
building is starting to look like it's
pretty boxy it's got a little bit of a
setback going on but there's a lot more
to go for that coming back to our ground
floor plan let's simply press our option
button select one of our external walls
command up up and let's repeat those
steps for the upstairs so simply drawing
around all of the shape and then jumping
to our 3D we'll see we have our Second
Story modeled within a matter of seconds
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed the video if you did the
playlist to the side of me has all of
the current tutorials from this series
if you love the videos make sure you
smash that subscribe button down below
as well as the notification Bell to be
notified when the next episode of this
course goes live but like I said that is
all for me so I'll see you next Monday